these aren't Ferrari cylinders that
Sufjan is repairing but that's exactly
what he wants to do one day ever since
he was a child he's dreamed of becoming
a mechanic into the picture I love
everything to do with mechanics the 29
year old will finish his training in a
few months and he'll have to find a job
Sufjan feels ready but he's concerned
about his background I admit that I
wouldn't say I'm from molenbeek on my
applications I know what people would
think I'll say that I'm from 1080
Brussels not 1080 Mahlon being big all
of the trainees here are doing a
one-year apprenticeship many of them are
school dropouts or have been unemployed
and now want to learn a trade this is
the bond V Center a social project that
teaches young adults a hands-on
profession it's in the heart of Moreland
Beck the neighborhood has struggled with
a bad reputation since the attacks in
France and Belgium
it's young confident residents want
things to return to normal this is a
place that invests in its young people
josh fluey is the project leader as well
as a social worker and hostel director
he explains that his trainees learn to
become mechanics or bricklayers
whichever trade they choose it'll help
them get employment and become
independent josh is angry that people
look down on his boys just because of
their postcode but ok where my mechanics
from as long as he's enthusiastic and
does a good job whether he's Belgian
rockin or Italian a mechanic is a
mechanic group has even won national
trade competitions that makes them proud
but they all wish they didn't always
have to prove themselves just because
they're from morlin Beck